so one of the moves that we knew the
Trump administration would be trying to
make pretty quickly after Trump's
inauguration was to move the embassy of
the United States in Israel from Tel
Aviv to Jerusalem and I've explained why
this is an absolutely terrible idea and
the gist of it is that within Israel
there are of course many people that
consider Jerusalem to be the capital of
the country but internationally
Jerusalem is a disputed territory it's
sort of like if internationally
Washington DC was the capital of the
United States but imagine that
internally we sort of thought that New
York was our capital but we were in a
land dispute with Canada / New York
right sort of an analogous situation an
imaginary analogy currently West
Jerusalem is considered part of Israel
East Jerusalem is considered part of the
Palestinian territories with the old
city within that under Israeli control
but with a particular part of the old
city with jurisdiction given back to the
Palestinian Authority very complicated
situation but the long and short of it
is that the future of Jerusalem is by
all reasonable accounts part of what
would be negotiated in a peace agreement
hypothetically if we ever got to that
point again and of course with Jared
Kushner leading that crusade doesn't
seem like we're gonna get there anytime
soon so internationally Tel Aviv is the
capital of Israel that's where the
United States has had its embassy Donald
Trump's choice for ambassador to Israel
we learned pretty early on was going to
be and eventually it became David
Friedman and as soon as we knew that
David Friedman was going to be the guy
to be the US ambassador to Israel we
knew that a top priority would be to
move the embassy to Jerusalem Friedman
is the epitome of a right-wing extremist
on the issue of Israel he is of the
mindset that more settlements are good
which is in the spectrum of views on
settlements to really understand how
wacky that position is you've got to
understand what the sort of range of
positions is and the range tends to be
something like demolish all settlements
and get out completely give that land
back to Palestinians
stop building new ones but presume that
existing settlements may be allowed to
stay if there are meaningful land swaps
in exchange as part of a peace agreement
get the the current settlements to stay
but only if there's some kind of
integration with Palestinians right
there's all these sort of different
views the extremists view is not only
are the settlements not a problem but we
should be building even more settlements
and that's the view of Donald Trump's
ambassador to Israel David Friedman so
completely retrograde on that issue and
Trump has been touting that moving the
embassy to Jerusalem will actually be a
good thing with respect to possible
peace talks between Israelis and
Palestinians because it'll take
Jerusalem off the table right trump's
idea is listen right now the issue of
Jerusalem is a negotiating issue if we
just move the embassy to Jerusalem and
more importantly recognize Jerusalem as
the capital of Israel we're taking it
off the table for future negotiations
and of course I cannot imagine a more
short-sighted and childish view of the
situation the unilateral decision to
move the embassy without it being part
of an agreement is only going to inflame
the situation and make it more difficult
to even get people to the table to do
the negotiation and of course violence
is escalating completely predictably at
least 25 already dead in the Gaza Strip
in the midst of growing protests against
this move of the embassy Hamas of course
benefiting greatly vowing even more
protest tomorrow mas as I've told you
always acting with no regard whatsoever
for the safety of the Palestinian people
and this will in turn be used to justify
even more pushback by Israeli forces and
the cycle continues this endless cycle
and at the end of the day we see who it
is that influences Donald Trump its
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu a vile
right winger connected to the most
extreme elements of the Israeli
political spectrum he has gotten just
major concessions from Trump over the
last several weeks
Trump has announced that he's going to
pull the United States out of the Iran
which Netanyahu of course loves hearing
from Donald Trump it's a totally
backwards move geopolitically Trump now
following through on moving the embassy
to Jerusalem initially a sort of
provisional embassy with a bigger
build-out coming in the future that's
another move that strengthens Benjamin
Netanyahu's hardliner stands and at this
point I'm genuinely unsure about whether
Netanyahu has even offered Donald Trump
anything in response for all of this
right in other words did Netanyahu
simply manipulate Trump into doing what
he wants Trump to do without having to
offer anything or is there some quid pro
quo here right either real or promised
or hypothetical going on in the
background it's possible that there is a
quid pro quo it's also very possible
that Donald Trump has merely done this
because he's convinced that it's the
correct or cool thing to do and Benjamin
Netanyahu has bamboozled him into doing
it and when we talk about the future of
Benjamin Netanyahu in Israel a guy who
is the subject of multiple criminal
investigations a guy whose wife is also
being looked into for criminal activity
it's the type of guy Trump loves right
Benjamin Netanyahu is in the direction
although not clearly as far as people
like Rodrigo Duterte
and president air Dhawan of Turkey and
Kim jong-un of North Korea these are the
types that Trump likes and that's why
it's not even remotely surprising that
Netanyahu seems to have Owen Putin who
can forget Putin Netanyahu seems to have
Donald Trump effectively wrapped around
his finger disastrous decision made here
and I'm sure we'll continue to talk
about the horrible consequences over the
coming weeks and months the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership